I've just I've always been a fan of the
genre I never stopped reading it and
when I when I somebody found I had time
to write a novel and I was casting about
for what I would do I landed on this one
pretty quickly yeah I've it I I would
suspect that young adult is the genre
that um cast the widest net right now
actually I think thanks to the success
of harry potter and you've got your
twilight's and this and that but it
doesn't really young adult stuff doesn't
apply to young adults anymore
no no I was I was I would have been
devastated if they'd hated it and they
didn't and it's very tough to get a read
on a on a twelve-year-old sometimes as
emotional as they are they can also be
very guarded or especially a
twelve-year-old boy very unexpressed but
no